- 'SUP, LADIES?
- WATCH THIS, WATCH THIS.
YO, TYRELL.
- YO, WHAT UP, LAWRENCE?
- HEY, MAN, YOU WANNA PLAY
FRONT HAND, BACK HAND?
- I DON'T KNOW THAT GAME, MAN.
- IT'S EASY, DOG.
ALL YOU GOTTA DO IS SAY
"FRONT HAND" OR "BACK HAND."
- AIGHT, FRONT HAND.
- UGH!
[all laughing]
BAM! I GOT YOU, SUCKA!
- OH, OKAY.
OKAY.
I SEE HOW IT IS NOW.
- COME ON, MAN.
COME ON, YOU KNOW
THAT [bleep] WAS FUNNY.
- BACK HAND.
- HUH?
- IT'S STILL MY MOVE, RIGHT?
I CHOOSE BACK HAND THIS TIME.
- REALLY?
- BACK HAND, [bleep]!
- UH--
all: OH!
[laughter]
- GOD DAMN!
- LOOK, TY, I'M SORRY.
BUT I AIN'T SORRY,
KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
I MEAN, YOU ASKED FOR IT.
I MEAN,
YOU LITERALLY ASKED FOR IT.
- FRONT HAND!
- WHAT? NO.
WHY YOU WANNA HIT--
- I...GOT IT!
I FIGURED IT OUT.
FRONT HAND!
NO, BACK HAND!
BACK HAND!
- NO, LOOK, LOOK.
DUDE, HEY, IF YOU WANT ME
TO SLAP YOU ACROSS THE FACE
BACK HAND, I'LL DO IT, OKAY?
DON'T THINK I WON'T DO IT.
BUT YOU KNOW THAT
I'M [bleep] WITH YOU, RIGHT?
I MEAN, THERE AIN'T NO GAME
CALLED "FRONT HAND, BACK HAND."
- OH!
- RIGHT. YEAH, YEAH.
- OH, DOG!
YEAH, I GET IT.
I GET IT.
ALL RIGHT,
ALL RIGHT, ALL RIGHT.
AS SOON AS I GET GOOD
AT FRONT HAND, BACK HAND,
YOU WANNA STOP PLAYING.
- PLAY WHAT, MAN?
I MADE IT UP SO I COULD
SMACK YOU IN THE FACE.
- I'M ABOUT TO SMACK YOU
IN THE FACE
AS SOON AS IT'S MY TURN.
BACK HAND!
- THERE AIN'T NO TURNS,
[bleep],
'CAUSE IT AIN'T NO GAME.
- YOU AIN'T GOT NO GAME,
[bleep].
BACK HAND!
AGHH!
FRONT HAND.
- LOOK, I DON'T KNOW
IF YOU'RE [bleep] WITH ME
AT THIS POINT OR WHAT...
BUT I DON'T WANNA...
SMACK A [bleep] NO MORE.
- [exaggerated laughter]
WHERE YOU GOING THEN?
OKAY, FORFEIT.
FORFEIT, [bleep], I WIN!
I WIN FRONT HAND, BACK HAND!
OKAY.
ME AND YOU.
[bleep], ME AND YOU.
HMM?
BACK HAND.
AH!